[Music]
in Fight Club sub news oh I like that
submitted by Aisha Lula JK fans since
2012 a substitute teacher started a
fight club so the kids would find him
cool oh hell yeah it's not really cool
is this Hawaii
that's stupid wha why cuz he's a [ __ ]
loser that didn't that was a loser cuz
he wants kids to find him cool you're
telling me that if a teacher created a
special ed Fight Club that you would not
be down yeah that's exactly what I'm
saying
why would I support special ed Fight
Club yeah why is that to be [ __ ]
kids it's not special no why'd you say
special you're special and so I thought
this is I thought this guy's really cool
cuz the old MMA place and me and Joe
trained at our sensei it was like any
time you guys have beef and you guys in
it throw it out come to my gym and it's
a safe place to throw down so I'm like I
said you gave this cool so this guy no
he just wants to be cool yeah but he
might be a wrestling culture of you guys
want to throw it down into the wind when
you get thrown out and I'll be cool you
maybe think he would be cool if he did
it for the purpose of the kids letting
off energy but he's doing it solely for
the fact that the kids think he's cool
can I tell you guys something you two
woman you don't even know what you're
talking about right now I want to tell
you this right now okay
shut it okay I'm gonna tell you what the
real is yeah tell me the real the real
is this being a substitute teacher is
the hardest job that you could ever have
I don't even think it's right harder
than being a green beret in a list of
things what I read it somewhere on the
weakest are you sure he's not a teacher
for special
let me finish let me finish up it's not
special
so it's a substitute have the hardest
job okay then more than the President of
the United States that's what I so read
in the Wikipedia and green beret yep
right you get it right
substitute teacher she says the easiest
shakes you have no emotional attachment
with these [ __ ] kids you say she did
she say she [ __ ] you all right lady and
you shut your mouth - okay what I'm
saying is this all right this guy has a
hard job they don't respect him when he
goes in this class oh there's [ __ ]
that's what they say in their heads no
way I was in right he's oh we don't we
don't have to listen to him because he's
not the real teacher like Jack and
whatever the kids right so this guy
wants respect right so he's like hey
what about Fight Club like what yeah
let's do it
so he's they think the chairs and the
desk a firm a circle you go in the
center
go ahead you know if I was teacher okay
you give cocaine I'll be the coolest one
cocaine don't do your homework you get
no homework I take my story I take my uh
I take my statements back you have the
scoop on everything thank you so much I
[ __ ] up that's this teacher in the
world he gave us cocaine it made us
fighting all right I would give you I
would give you fancy ice cream
oh it's fancy ice cream like you know
from salt & straw yeah sea salt
yeah right yeah the kids would be like
what the [ __ ] this guy's cool right what
some cocaine they snip the cocaine right
you say if he was type of teacher you'd
still be like either cool teacher he's
old enough to handle cocaine and salt &
straw and yet yeah exactly if you have
diabetes I go you don't get this you
don't get the I'll give you a Mac yeah
yeah so you lose the way yeah you know
become a thinker Tycho's like 10 years
older no he's not ready to handle all
those drugs me or some childhood
no I mean it was oh yeah I thank God
wait thought what are you doing okay I
think about sixteen the trike okay
they're pretty solid I'm advocating for
Bunder saying like you're more
biologically solid if you like ten I do
that sixteen okay man hard drugs [ __ ]
up my brain dude that's too [ __ ] up
people are gonna say this video and send
it psycho later alright so basically in
[Music]
16 years
yeah so this takes place in Connecticut
the sub named Ryan's 23 year old
especially in Connecticut ale my [ __ ]
out there guess there's a lot of things
to be cool like fight no but [ __ ] this
teacher yeah so Ryan here he no don't do
it mine he's putting his ass up just be
careful I see it look like a whales
[ __ ] bull cuz I'm communicating with
whales right now you don't even know my
[ __ ] yeah it's a pity isn't it have you
smelled anything so far nothing there
was still the first part I do get a
little whiff and I gagged and I was like
oh god I can't throw up on camera but he
smells kind of good right yeah well you
get used to it damn it's a gasoline you
know you smoke smoke gas when you and
your brother farted I know I know
okay it runs in the family that's our
thing earlier like does it run in the
family you guys were too long I don't
even have to put that part on you guys
edit it out you know know what you know
we're keeping that at this well let's
move on then alright so this guy he
would set up these fights and just like
Bobby said he would move the desks and
stuff and create like like a ring
there's only one way to do it there's
only one away yeah and apparently there
were about four boys involved between
the ages of 14 and 16 perfect age yeah
and police found video and in one of the
videos that they found on these kids
fighting that they saw that these kids
were swinging full force at each other's
heads with open hand and strikes
come on Fight Club of course yes the
only way yeah at one point you actually
call pankration if it's open head so
they're doing this he didn't want to
they're saving their knuckles
at one point there was a
sixteen-year-old kid that started
vomiting he's a [ __ ] yeah this
fourteen-year-old kid sure that he was
traumatized by the fights and that's
when police got involved and apparently
the rat yeah number one rule of Fight
Club
yeah Fight Club Annie don't vomit he's
only playing victim he was probably the
first one in my life [ __ ] yeah and then
when the cops come I was so traumatized
they're not gonna make soap out of his
fat yeah and then what the sub is gonna
go to what he's gonna go to court yeah I
just blame pile of dirty I wasn't me
other guy with the blonde here with the
spiky hair the boyish are open that guy
look I yeah and so they're saying that
sometimes these matches would be
unevenly matched for fun yeah to keep
things interesting so it'd be like a
smaller kid with a bigger kid Bobby
leaved out of frame to hide his drinking
but it was so [ __ ] obvious could you
see him leaving with and it's long
talking to so the cameras hunter you're
gonna love it
yeah Ryan can we see video it's a white
job he looks like a student he does yeah
he looks like a student himself
Connecticut what the [ __ ] and his lips
look like a mustache and he looks like
he plucks his eyebrows oh yeah maybe
it's just then he's really trying to be
cool
no he for sure plucks his eyebrows stem
he doesn't even clean them he gets him
shaped he looks like he collects Nazi
memorabilia right oh yeah he does I'm
being right now this guy right here this
is an untrustworthy face when white
dudes look like this you walk right away
this guy white what are the signs what
are some of the signs for the lips right
there slits they're like you can't kiss
that it looks like Joker's lips exactly
you'll get a paper cut if you [ __ ]
kiss that guy his skin look at the skin
it's not it's Twilight vampire it's from
the Twilight movies the shimmer to it
he's got the [ __ ] German Nazi Youth
haircut right yeah you can't just the
[ __ ] is that it's his third eye is his
third eye so he's mythological okay in
the good [ __ ] [ __ ] is this suit made
out of recycled material yeah I think
that's that teacher cardigan the
cardigan
that's a Cardian it's that teacher made
carton carton you know here's the thing
though look at the guy he's young
himself you know cuz you know people
like you know at me I'm 46 but people
think that I'm younger because I you
know I'm dumb I'm kind of domina you
know I fart you know on cameras Dom is
there video of the Fight Club because I
want to do some research
nope well he's a young guy who just
wants to fit in right he wants to be
cool you're telling me that if your
substitute teacher did this you'd think
they're a loser I think they'll be
[ __ ] dope okay I would have thought
that is awesome yeah yeah I would have
loved it there's no homework just
fighting all day I feel like this is a
customary thing in the Philippines like
when we were younger
our parents used to like birth during
birthday parties put gloves on the kids
and just have a go at each other and we
they would place the bets as to which
you do [ __ ] fighting with children yeah
did you grow up in the Philippines yeah
and that's what we did I boxed the hell
out of my cousin Edward and he cried
like a [ __ ] every time my mom makes so
much money off of me handsome and
handsome man II Pacquiao yeah how do you
think that that happened and how come we
haven't had a bad many pack of you in
America because this stuff is being
weeded out of our seats out of our
education system is wrong we'd have so
many better boxers if we had this yeah
but it's just [ __ ] this should be PE
yeah Fight Club yeah why don't we have
boxing in our PE I have before it if
people petition for it and then there's
a structured class and then the kids
know going into it that that's what's
gonna
and they're not just thrown into it yeah
and full face mask yeah but the fear is
what's funny yeah it needs to be the
element of surprise what doesn't need to
be funny because cuz we were raising a
bunch of weaklings in this country yeah
there was a time that we could crush
people's faces with our hands but you
said you don't like confrontation I
don't that's why we that's like weeks in
a row I like three weeks in a row you
got beat up that's what I'm saying I'm a
part of the weak country look at this
little we we used to crush people face
we as Americans back in the day before I
was alive face you crushing
I'm not crushing no faces [ __ ] I'm
crushing your [ __ ] my point is is this
America okay is that we have to stronk
in our kids we got faster Singaporean
stuff to do yeah we have Canadian fans
Ozzy fan I think in the world because
can I say this yeah we have the war
against the robots we need the Ostroff
we need to crush metal skulls or you
could just be geeky coders yeah destroy
him that way
oh you know for my jujitsu that's going
to DAP you know force a robot to tap out
download some viruses in that [ __ ]
robot
[Music]